the Mariana Trench is the deepest point
on earth so deep that if you dropped
Mount Everest inside its peak would
still be more than a kilometer
underwater so deep that no light reaches
the bottom and if you could feel it the
pressure would be about equal to the
weight of 48 jumbo jets yet somehow life
finds a way a very weird life the truth
is at first glance you wouldn't be very
impressed it's gonna be this kind of
silky grey green sediment but if you put
out some food some of the planet's
strangest creatures would emerge from
the darkness like these they're
crustaceans called amphipods and some
individuals can grow up to 30
centimeters long or about the size of an
American football now like lobsters
these animals have hard exoskeletons
made of calcium carbonate which you
normally wouldn't find down here more
than ten thousand meters down because
once you pass 45 hundred meters or so
the pressure is so great and the
temperature is so low that calcium
carbonate dissolves
but these amphipods have a secret weapon
or rather shield the crustaceans are
covered with an armor made of aluminum
which they synthesize in their bodies
using aluminum found in the sea floor
it's a good thing too because those
shells are their best defense against
something else lurking in the abyss the
Marianas snailfish aka the deepest fish
ever discovered which scientists have
seen more than 8,000 meters down and
there are a lot of strange things about
these fish they have flexible bones
which scientists think helps them
withstand pressure they're blind because
well when it's that dark there's no
point in seeing
and their skin is translucent so you can
see their internal organs but they're
also one of the trenches top predators
and if you want proof check out this
terrifying x-ray image now snail fish
are certainly odd but then again you
haven't yet met Vezina 504 it's a
single-celled organism akin to a giant
amoeba in fact at about 10 centimeters
long it's one of the largest single
celled organisms on Earth the trench
also has what Bartlett calls these
little sea pigs they're small
transparent sea cucumbers that crawl
along the ocean floor on tentacle-like
lakes but perhaps the most surprising
thing you'll discover inside the Mariana
Trench is this plastic in 1998 a
remotely operated submersible detected a
plastic bag at ten thousand eight
hundred ninety-eight meters and in 2019
an explorer reported signs of plastic
debris even further down
what's more researchers have found micro
plastics inside the stomachs of
amphipods
in the Challenger Deep they called it
the deepest record of micro plastic
ingestion and all that goes to show that
even here in the most remote place on
the planet where only four people have
ever visited there are signs of our vast
impact on the world
[Music]